[Música]
cuál es el momento más importante en la
historia la humanidad responda en 100
caracteres o menos esa fue la pregunta
que me tocó cuando estaba postulando a
la universidad
me pregunte qué momento nos ha impactado
absolutamente a todos por igual sin
importar nuestra edad nuestra ubicación
geográfica nuestra religión o incluso
yendo un poco más allá nuestra especie
cuál fue mi respuesta aún no ha sucedido
será cuando podamos detener los impactos
del cambio climático
67 caracteres es ahora este preciso
momento el cual define nuestra historia
como humanidad todos nuestros logros
anteriores de poco habrán valido si no
logramos detener los impactos del cambio
climático
uno de esos desafíos es que según la
agencia de las naciones unidas para los
refugiados para el 2050 en tan sólo un
poco más de 30 años y con cifras
conservadoras habrá 250 millones de
refugiados alrededor del mundo debido a
los efectos del cambio climático los
refugiados son aquellas personas que se
ven obligadas a abandonar su lugar de
origen debido a por ejemplo los
conflictos armados y porque su vida
corre peligro un creciente una creciente
clase de refugiados son los conocidos
como los refugiados climáticos
según el diario internacional de
guardián el cambio climático traerá
consigo la crisis refugiados más grande
en esto de la humanidad millones de
personas se verán obligadas a abandonar
su lugar de origen debido al aumento de
sequías de inundaciones o por el alza
del nivel del mar además según el team
del centro del reino unido pero es el
tercer país más vulnerable a los efectos
del cambio climático
después de bangladesh y de honduras es
muy probable entonces que de esos 250
millones de personas muchos sean
peruanos esta situación hace que nos
preguntemos estamos preparados
para empezar a responder esa pregunta
primero debemos preguntarnos o saber
cómo es que bien los refugiados en la
actualidad hay millones de carpas de
suelo sin asfaltar de falta de agua y de
desagüe de falta de hospitales y
escuelas estos no son lugares donde las
personas pueden desarrollarse con
comodidad sin embargo vemos con
preocupación como este tipo de
asentamiento se empieza a esparcirse por
todo el planeta y cómo aumentan también
en tamaño como por ejemplo el campo de
refugiados en tu paloma en bangladesh
donde viven 800.000 personas esto es el
equivalente a la población de trujillo
la tercera ciudad más poblada de todo el
perú entonces son estas las ciudades del
futuro que va a pasar con estos millones
de personas que no van a tener casas en
el futuro este tema de las personas sin
hogar no es nada nuevo desde mediados
del siglo 20 los gobiernos de
latinoamérica de otras regiones idearon
programas conocidos como los programas
de vivienda social donde subsidiaban
proyectos para construir miles de casas
para así poder brindar las a bajo costo
a la población sin embargo vemos que
este diseño o esos proyectos estaban
lejos de las ciudades no contaban con
transporte público adecuado no brindaban
servicios como escuelas y mercados y el
diseño de las viviendas resultaba ser
muy pequeño y nos adecuada a las
necesidades de las personas es por eso
que estos proyectos de viviendas fueron
abandonados a los pocos años de haber
sido construidos o se convirtieron en
centros de crimen y de pobreza hace poco
los ángeles times publicó un especial
sobre la visión vice fallida en méxico
donde en la actualidad existen 5
millones de casas abandonadas como un
ejemplo del fracaso de este modelo de
hacer ciudad desde una mirada
completamente técnica y cuantitativa
pero muy poco humana
es por eso que no nos debería
sorprendernos que las naciones unidas
dice que este tipo de modelo de hacer
ciudad debería ser la última opción para
todos los refugiados que se aproximan en
el futuro pero sin embargo qué hacemos
cuando esa es la última opción que nos
queda ese es el caso de kiribati tuvalú
las pequeñas islas que van a desaparecer
en las próximas décadas por el alza del
nivel del mar su más de 100.000
habitantes van a tener que abandonar la
isla y de 15 a fiji la isla más cercana
entonces es por casos como los de
kiribati tuvalú que ha llegado el
momento de repensar cómo hacemos las
ciudades del futuro
por suerte el perú es uno de los pocos
países en el mundo que cuenta con planes
de reubicación preventiva pues hoy en
día existe la suficiente tecnología para
poder predecir cómo van a ser los
efectos del cambio climático y así poder
actuar con tiempo y planificar las
ciudades de manera adecuada sin embargo
vemos con preocupación como en el perú
se sigue utilizando el mismo modelo de
hacer ciudad que les conté hace un rato
esto es una un gran desafío pero también
es una oportunidad para poder hacer las
cosas bien para poder mejorar la calidad
de vida de millones de refugiados pero a
la vez trata de disminuir los impactos
sociales y ambientales de las ciudades
del futuro es así como nace casa
ciudades auto sostenibles amazónicas un
proyecto que busca construir con la
población recomendaciones y mejoras para
la creación de ciudades con énfasis en
las ciudades para los refugiados
climáticos nosotros desde casa
entendemos que las ciudades no son
solamente la suma de las viviendas o de
los edificios construir un nuevo mercado
con ser una nueva escuela no va a
reemplazar tu escuela lo que ha forjado
lazos emocionales con el espacio con el
que vives por muchísimos años eso es lo
difícil de hacer ciudades como preservar
ese sentido de pertenencia como
preservar ese sentido de identidad y
entonces cómo crear ciudades que nos
hagan sentirnos como en casa
john turner fue un arquitecto inglés que
estudió las barriadas de lima en la
década de los sesentas y los setentas y
él fue quien dijo que las viviendas
producidas con participación ciudadana
son un vehículo infinitamente superior
para el desarrollo personal familiar y
social que aquella que simplemente se
entregaba un ejemplo muy estudiado de
este tipo de metodología para hacer
ciudades está acá mismo en lima en comas
en un proyecto de vivienda social
conocido como previo o proyecto
experimental de vivienda que fue
construido hacia los finales de los años
60 en donde se contempló cómo es que las
casas se iban a ir transformándose en el
tiempo para adaptarse a las necesidades
de los usuarios muchos vecinos de ahí
siguen viviendo
y vemos como han ido cambiando sus casas
para adaptarse a sus necesidades
nosotros desde casa entendemos que se
sentirse en casa va más allá del ámbito
de las casas entonces por eso trabajamos
con la población en la generación de
espacios públicos de barrios y de
ciudades
nos enfocamos en la generación de medio
de vida que sean sostenibles e
inclusivos porque para nosotros más que
entregar viviendas lo importante es
entregar posibilidades de desarrollo
para los desplazados por eso trabajamos
con las personas en la generación de
espacios públicos y comunitarios que
fomenten y permitan este desarrollo no
es tanto el producto final lo que nos
interesa sino más que en otra más que
todo trabajar con ellas en el proceso
mismo entendiendo entonces sus
necesidades sus deseos y generando así
conocimiento en común no solamente nos
importa preguntar qué es lo que quieren
sino involucrarlos en el proceso para
así poder generar soluciones que sean
pertinentes a su realidad somos un
equipo multidisciplinario de arquitectos
ingenieros ambientales y sociólogos y
además trabajamos con estudiantes
universitarios con los gobiernos locales
pero sobre todo con la población misma
en la generación de propuestas que sean
pertinentes a su realidad
trabajamos en iquitos donde el
emblemático barrio de belén está siendo
reubicados porque según la marina de
guerra del perú dentro de 20 ó 40 años
el río amazonas y rita ya unirán su
cauce las viviendas flotantes y sobre
pilares que se encuentran ahora sobre el
río itaya no van a poder soportar el
volumen y la velocidad del río más
caudaloso del mundo es por eso que el
ministerio vivienda construcción y
saneamiento está construyendo 2 mil
quinientas viviendas para 16.000
personas hasta el momento se han
construido 169 casas de aproximadamente
40 metros cuadrados con un diseño poco
adaptado para familias que tienen
integrantes de más de 4 personas además
las casas no cuentan con agua desagüe al
igual que más del 60% de las casas de
loreto es en este contexto en donde casa
decidió trabajar con la población para
mejorar su calidad de vida
desde ahora los habitantes también
además viajan por más de una hora en las
vecinas sobre todo a las mujeres ya no
pueden dedicarse a esas actividades
comerciales porque tienen que quedarse
en sus casas cuidando a sus hijos
trabajamos con la población con los
buenos locales y conocimientos
universitarios en la generación de un
sistema productivo amazónico que busca
promover actividades laborales para el
cultivo y la transformación de alimentos
primero identificamos cuáles son esas
actividades que ya existían
identificando también sus
potencialidades y sus desafíos
por ejemplo descubrimos que la población
ya sabía sobre técnicas constructivas y
que también ya se dedicaba al cultivo de
frijoles de yuca y de plátano pero
también vimos que cocinaban estos
alimentos en parrillas cuya exposición
de humo les generaba a todos y también
les causaba problemas a la vista es por
eso que con ellos exigimos también
trabajar cómo mejorar estas actividades
que ya existían como por ejemplo a
través del uso de energías renovables
luego de haber identificado cuáles serán
estas actividades generamos con ellos
una red articulada estas actividades que
además las integramos con los programas
de desarrollo socioeconómico que ya
existían de los gobiernos locales y por
último de parte de los arquitectos vivos
cómo se integraba esto al diseño urbano
de las ciudades cuando estos aliados y
con la población decidimos probar tres
prototipos o propuestas semilla de esta
red para identificar si efectivamente
funcionado no pasamos con ellos también
el proceso de construcción colaborativo
trabajamos en un sistema de captación
almacenamiento y distribución de agua y
lluvia en una cocina mejorada y en una
parrilla solar integramos estas tres
cosas en una cocina comunal que fue
integrada a la maloca que es el centro
comunitario de la nueva ciudad el
sistema de captación almacenamiento y
distribución de agua lluvia utiliza una
serie de tubos que pueden ser aumentados
o disminuidos según las necesidades de
los usuarios y además
utilizan menos espacio que un sistema de
tanques tradicionales por último puede
ser utilizado como un muro permeable que
utiliza y promueve una mejor ventilación
algo que es bastante necesario en un
lugar de altas temperaturas y de alta
humedad y así también buscamos rescatar
sistemas constructivos tradicionales en
la parrilla solar utilizar los propios
rayos del sol para poder ser para poder
cocinar los alimentos sin necesidad de
humo además los alumnos que trabajaron
en esta tecnología la innovación al
hacerla de fácil y rápida implementación
por último para los días de lluvia o los
días nublados o incluso para cocinar
durante la noche la cocina mejorada
utiliza menos leña menos carbón y menos
aserrín que una parrilla tradicional y
además a través del uso de chimeneas
disminuye el contacto directo con el
humo reduciendo así las enfermedades
respiratorias y oftalmológicas es con
ellos con las personas que trabajamos en
el proceso que se les entrega un
certificado técnico los que les permita
no solamente construir estas tecnologías
en otras comunidades sino también a
través del uso de ella en actividades
que ya existían como los comedores
generar nuevas nuevas fuentes de
ingresos diversas para necesidades
diversas de la población
por ejemplo hace poco está la cocina fue
utilizada para recaudar fondos para uno
de los dirigentes que había caído
enferma
y es que de esto se trata de generar
nuevas fuentes de empleo y posibilidades
de desarrollo para la población a través
de la construcción de espacios
comunitarios que promuevan su
prosperidad y su bienestar
marcus que es un dirigente de la nueva
ciudad de belem dijo esto mejor que yo
lo que busca casa es generar
conocimientos y capacidades en la
población para que sean capaces de
adaptarse a los cambios climáticos y
sociales del futuro lo que busca casa
entonces es generar ciudadanía y
personas que sean capaces de ser agentes
de cambio para la producción de ciudades
que sean pensadas para y por la gente
eso es un primer paso un desafío de
largo aliento también venimos trabajando
con la población en la generación de una
guía de diseño urbano de planificación
para la célula baja buscando así reducir
la creación de ciudades que no se
adapten a esta geografía y esta sociedad
única
pero qué pasaría si también trabajáramos
en la costa o en la sierra qué pasaría
si mañana nos enteramos que tenemos que
abandonar nuestras casas porque ya no va
a haber agua o porque el barrio el mar
poco a poco va a andar nuestro barrio
como se imaginan que van a hacer esas
ciudades del futuro
todos somos refugiados climáticos
gracias
[Aplausos]